My name is Rahma. Uh I have the moment
that my younger sibling expressed that
she no longer felt peace at Islam and
she said that she was Christian now. Uh
do
>> my sister my little sister.
>> No no no please speak loudly.
>> Oh uh I repeat again
>> just go to the question.
>> Uh due to my knowledge uh I have limited
knowledge. So please me to give
understand to my sister. She asking me
why does the Quran seem so similar to
Bible?
>> Why why is Quran sound so similar to
>> Yes. And so if they are so similar
doesn't mean that the Quran copy the
Bible and she believe that Muhammad
there is no uh true messenger. The
prophet Muhammad know a true messenger.
the question that when there are so many
similarities
between the Quran and the Bible so there
are high possibilities that Quran has
been copied from the Bible so therefore
she doesn't believe in prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him that's a very good
question this reply I've g I've given in
my talk is the Quran God's word so one
of the option is that Quran was copied
from the Bible and I've analyzed Is this
time does not permit I'll just say in
brief if Quran has copied from the
Bible. Do you know there are hundreds of
scientific error in the Bible?
Quran speaks about creation of the
universe. Bible speaks about the
creation of the universe.
The Bible says
that
almighty God created light on the first
day and created the sun on the third
day. How can the source of light be
created later? Unscientific.
Bible says Almighty God created the sun,
the bigger light to rule the day and the
moon, the lesser light to rule the
night. Bible says light of the moon is
its own. Same thing Quran repeats Allah
has created the sun and the moon. The
sun having its own light, moon having
reflected light, borrowed light in
copying. Quran has changed it.
So now
imagine Quran is copying from the Bible
and correcting the mistakes.
Can a normal human being correct the
mistake which was unknown 1400 years
ago? 1400 years ago we did not know that
the light of the moon was its own light.
So can a normal human being
do it 1400 years ago? And the answer is
no.
I can keep on going. For example, the
Bible says Almighty God created the
trees and the vegetables on the third
day and sun on the fourth day. How can
the vegetable kingdom come without the
sunlight? Unscientific.
The Quran says we created Allah created
the heaven and the earth in
six ayam. Bible says created in six days
24 hours day. The Quran says the day in
the Quran is ayam long period. So
scientists have no problem in the
Quranic version six long periods but
disagree with the Bible 6 24 days. That
means the Quran copied from the Bible
and corrected it. There are two options.
Yes, if there are similarities, it can
be that the later book copied from the
first book or the source is common. The
source of the original Injil and the
Quran is common. The Bible is the
corrupted form of the Injil. In the
original Injil, there were no
contradiction. There were no scientific
errors. The Bible is the corrupted form
of the Injil and Quran is the original
last and final revelation of Allah. The
Bible is the ear the Injil is the
earlier revelation of Allah. The present
Bible is the corrupted form of Injil.
Therefore, there are contradiction.
There are scientific errors.
There is word of God mixed with the word
of prophet, word of Even pornography is
there.
If you give me a million dollar and you
ask me to read Ezekiel 24:24 I will not
not million rupia million dollar not
rupia million rupia no value
million dollar I will not read because
there is obscinity pornography
others may read I will not read so this
cannot be the word of god so that the
reason if similarities are they can be
copied but if there are similarities are
there but the mistakes are corrected.
Impossible. No human being can do that.
No human being can correct the mistakes
which was not known to the human being
that time.
In Bible there are hundreds of
contradiction, hundreds of scientific
errors in the Quran. No contradiction.
So you copied and you corrected
only God can do that. So therefore the
Quran is the last and final revelation
of God. The Bible is a corrupted form of
injil the given to Isaam.
Allah did not think it fit to preserve
the previous revelations because the
previous revelations were meant for a
particular time period was meant for a
particular group of people. Since the
Quran is the last and final revelation,
not only meant for the Muslims or the
Arabs, meant for the whole of humanity.
Allah says in Surah Hij chapter number
15 verse number N, we have revealed the
Quran and we shall guard it from
corruption.